Home Secretary pretty Patel has
condemned what she called utterly vile
scenes in South London in which 15
police officers were injured last night
Metropolitan Police say they have been
called to investigate reports of a large
unlicensed street party but the scene
descended into violence when they tried
to encourage the crowd to leave well we
can get now a former as sky News's mark
white who's in West London mark tell us
more well in terms of this disorder it
was serious and sustained for a while
the police came under a heel of missiles
bottles bricks other items that were
thrown at officers as he tried to deal
with this disorder at times they had to
pull back and regroup because they
weren't in at that time
there are public order Kate wearing
helmets and carrying shields and a light
because the disorder that broke out was
was fairly rapid in the way that it
deteriorated as you said the Home
Secretary has said this morning that
those scenes are utterly vile she is
raising it as a matter of urgency now
with the Metropolitan Police
Commissioner Cressida dick in the
meantime Scotland Yard have issued a
statement about this disorder they say
the police were called to Cecelia Road
Lambeth and Nev on the evening of
Wednesday the 24th of June - multiple
reports of large unlicensed music event
in the street officers attended to
encourage the crowd to leave the
location but they did not engage with
the police the event continued and more
officers attended the scene and the
group became hostile towards officers
the statement goes on to say in total 15
officers were injured none seriously
although two did require hospital
treatment and they also say a small
number of police vehicles were damaged
that four people have been arrested they
were detained for assault and public
order offences and they remain in police
custody now police today of course we're
beginning be began a detail
investigation into this disorder there's
quite a lot of footage that circulating
on social media shows the really violent
scenes that erupted for quite a while so
police will be trawling through those
images and of course CCTV as well with a
view to trying to identify those
involved in a disorder so you can expect
that that number of four arrested will
increase as as the day's progress but
Adam this in terms of the the
seriousness of the incident clearly it
was serious but police have really been
concerned for some time about the
potential for wide scale and widespread
disorder as the lockdown begins to
loosen were not at the stage of course
where the lockdown has been fully lifted
but the combination of really good
weather like we had yesterday and and
clearly was warm overnight as well and
it's going to be warm in the days ahead
coupled with people who have been
effectively unable to go out and to
socialize for some period of time is you
know the the perfect storm in terms of
the potential for these events to get
out of control as I say you know very
violent disorder condemned by the Home
Secretary unlikely to get a robust
policing response to future events